الى ملف اخر الان حيث اعلن نادي الاسير
الفلسطيني ان السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
ابلغت الحركه الاسرائيليه استشهاد الاسير
الشيخ خضر عدنان بعد اضراب عن الطعام
استمر سبعه وثمانين يوما رفضا الاعتقاله
قال النادي ان الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اغتال
الشيخ خضر عدنان عن سبق اصرار واعلنت ثم
مصلحه السجون الاسرائيليه وفاه الاسير
الفلسطيني خضر عدنان البالغ من العمر 44
عاما وقالت انه عثر عليه فاقدا للوعي داخل
زنزانته لسجن الانسان ونقل الى المستشفى
حيث توفي لاحقا حسب الروايه الاسرائيليه
ويشار لنا الشيخ عدنان متزوج ولديه تسعه
ابناء واعتقل اثنتي عشره مره وقضى في سجون
الاحتلال نحو 8 سنوات خاضى خلالها سته
اضرابات عن الطعام احتجاجا على اعتقاله
الاداري والتعرضه لاجراءات تعسفيه داخل
المعتقل
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من رام الله مراسل الجزيره
سمير ابو شمال سمير مرحبا بك معنا اذا ما
الذي جرى مع الشيخ خضر عدنان وهو الذي كان
مضربا عن الطعام لسبعه
داخل السجن
نعم محمد المصلحه او اداره مصلحه السجون
الاسرائيليه تحدثت في بيانها العسكريه فجر
هذا اليوم بانها قد عثرت على الشيخ
خضر عدنان القيادي في حركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه الاسير في داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه فاقدا للوعي ومغمن عليه داخل
زلزالته في سجن نيدسان وقد تم نقله الى
مستشفى اساف هاروفي حيث حاولت الطواقم
الطبيه انعاشها ولكنها فشلت في ذلك وتم
الاعلان عن وفاته في داخل السجون
الاسرائيليه